oh boy I'm walking into the Halloween
for the return of Michael Myers maze I
can't wait to do this I love the
original Halloween I watched all them on
one through six now to go into four oh
man and what are we gonna get inside
here some Loomis some Michael Myers and
Daniel Harris's character we're gonna
see I can't wait
what a fail
I quit I don't get we don't get paid
enough for this [ __ ] I don't know why I
agreed to do that [ __ ] that was awesome
a lot of jump scares but fun jump scares
they did a really great job recreating
the look of Halloween for I was really
impressed by this
all right we're monsters Universal
Monsters maze this is a big bed is a big
thing for me because I'm
how's the kid when you have
it wasn't for me I was in high school
the original dark universe this one
worked
Oh Wendy lost her mind
I can handle it then she turned into a
complete if the reflex thing you know
what I mean
[Music]
oh we interrupt this Halloween Horror
Nights video to what go to transformers
that's right more than meets the eye you
know I couldn't resist going to see some
transformers hanging out doing my thing
we're here at the stranger things won
the big headliner of the horror night I
love stranger things yeah I love strange
things do both good seasons I wonder how
many Demi Gorgons were gonna get in
there we're gonna get an 11 or any of
the kids show up well morning what we're
gonna get
[Music]
I'm not gonna I wasn't at period that
daughter's gonna be emceeing 11 like
hold of olive Jeanette house breathe oh
that was really good like it was the way
was deciding spread the lights
everything like that really put you in
the bar but stranger things so I loved
that was a lot of money
what up guys so we just finished the
poltergeist maze it was a little bonus
one at the end but honestly it was
probably the best one it scared the [ __ ]
out of me the most it shook me to the
core what do you guys think that was my
favorite by far you also get a little
water element in this one also durian at
one point stopped walking and said when
do you go first completely done half way
dude scared the hell out of me I loved
the hell out of this I saw this movie in
the theaters and it scared me this small
maze scared me as much that entire movie
so it was a lot of good a lot of good
fun look at the big skeleton coming out
the big skull coming for your head all
that stuff and some of the designs in
the rooms excellent stuff excellent
videos shared like and yeah sure the
video so if you can show everybody how
scared or II was